50 ans de cinéma 150 films l'un de nos
meilleurs comédiens est sans doute le
plus attachant bernard blier est mort à
73 ans michel rocard près ferme rien de
plus pour la corse
il faut maintenant discuter lille est
bloquée réaction des syndicats le
mystère de la mosquée de bruxelles qui a
tué l'imam et son bibliothécaire
peut-être les premiers morts de la
sphère rochdi dustin hoffman et jodie
foster triomphe aux oscars à hollywood
marcelo pulse avec hôtel terminus sauve
l'honneur français bonsoir
c'était l'un des plus grands du cinéma
français lorsqu'au début de ce mois
toute la france a vu apparaître sa
silhouette diminué sur la scène où l'on
remettait les césar ce fut la
stupéfaction la france découvre et
brutalement que bernard blier était très
très malade il s'est éteint la nuit
dernière à l'âge de 73
merci à vous tous tout comme tous et je
suis très heureux de vous dire que ce
soir je suis particulièrement ému
maintenant je me dirige vers toi pour te
remettre ce césar d'honneur et quel
effet ça près de monnaie
ben ça me semble nous sommes troublés ça
me suis mis c'est pour couronner l'homme
l'artiste
oui un artiste et après ça vous dit
après ça il peut faire tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est ça une fois condamnable
c'est ça une fois qu'on a deux césars on
peut écrire et faire n'importe quoi
n'importe quelle connerie on est honoré
ya plus de risques
bernard blier ses 50 ans au service du
cinéma 150 films je vous le disais un
rôle clé dans le cinéma français une
place de grandes vedettes en italie où
il a tourné ses dernières années avec
les plus grands visconti monicelli
reavie résumer sa carrière en quelques
séquences c'est forcément la réduire
mais on peut tout de même tenté de lui
rendre hommage
georges bigot si vous avez une mémoire
d'éléphant et si vous aimez bien cinéma
vous devez vous souvenir de moi dans des
films qui vont de 1936 à 1939
j'ai tourné dans tous les films je
faisais tout je jouais un flic je jouais
un marchand de marrons avis trop je vous
faire de taxi jersey 2 dans la journée
quelques pas des gt gt sur un décor et
on devient régisseur de l'air mise en
dictant si vous avez une heure vous
allez venir faire le curé dans le film à
côté parce qu'une moi quelqu'un je
faisais touche considérer que le cinéma
était un truc qui consistait à faire des
cachetons à courir le cache de ilan à
endosser les costumes il appartient à
cette génération de grands acteurs qui
ont fait la qualité du cinéma français
depuis 40 ans faux culs cocu battu
content méchant futé balourd faucher rup
un truand militaire bourgeois il aura
donc tout jouer sans oublier molière
quelles nouvelles têtes et hichem c'est
dommage mais quoi nous sommes tous
mortels et chaque année pour soi
matthieu gibert non à dieu gilbert
asier l'espère
mais l'accord ne peut pas commencer
adieu gilbert amy noir voilà les faits
me when i'm a sifflé
well as pas typé est restée gare de
roanne et qui est infirmière sur la 3ème
oui ma petite fille vous reconnaitre
c'est du brutal tu sais pas ce qui me
rappelle cette espèce de drôlerie qu'on
buvait dans une petite touche de bienne
un point tellement loin de sa ligne
les volets rouges et la taulière une
blonde comac
quand elle s'appelait nom de dieu
lulu la nantaise aux problèmes sont ceux
qu'on peut résoudre avec de l'argent
voilà d'un comme vous aimiez si bien
dire
allez c'est pas que je m'ennuie mais
j'ai les choux qui mourut ainsi bien
pratique de se cacher derrière quelque
chose derrière une grimace derrière ça
derrière sa ligne horse derrière des
choses qui ne nous appartiennent pas qui
ne nous ressemble pas voilà mon seul ce
soir antenne 2 a modifié ses programmes
pour diffuser aussitôt après le journal
à 20h35 les tontons flingueurs un grand
classique dans lequel joue et oublier un
film de georges lautner georges lautner
vous êtes avec nous en duplex bon sens
vous avez donc fait les tontons
flingueurs vous avez une anecdote sur ce
film c'est difficile de résumer la vie
d'un ami à une anecdote si vous voulez
pour moi les tontons flingueurs ça a été
une anecdote en soit c'était un tout
avoir pour un jeune metteur en scène la
chance de faire un film avec des acteurs
comiques avec des dialogues d'audiard
c'était une partie de rigolade d'un bout
à l'autre
lorsque je voudrais surtout c'est que
puisqu'on voit les tontons flingueurs ce
soit on garde l'image de bernard tel
qu'il était dans ce film excusez moi
mais plaindre et lire plein de force
plein de vigueur
voilà georges lautner c'est un comédien
qui vous a étonné beaucoup vous avez
fait une dizaine de films avec lui je
crois oui j'ai fait beaucoup de films
que j'ai fait j'ai surtout réussi a
débuté dans ce métier parce qu'il m'a
aidé c'est grâce à lui que j'ai pu
débuter et évidemment qui m'a étonné cet
homme qui en disait moteur et puis tout
d'un coup il se mettait à pleurer il
faut communiquer une émotion
indescriptible
et puis tout d'un coup un autre moment
lui demander de vous faire rire et vous
fait rire c'était bien sûr qu'ils
étaient été visitées nord à chaque
moment parce qu'il est c'est surprenant
était surprenant dans le travail parce
qu'il était plein d'humour il était
surprenant à l'écran parce qu'il vous
donner des choses totalement inattendue
et imprévisible
alors justement comment on pouvait
situer un comédien comme ça parce que il
quand il était comique il était
complètement dans son rôle de dire s'il
connaît toujours à son rôle comment le
situer c'est très difficile vous savez
un comédien qui va qu'un éventail pareil
qui passe de l'émotion rire pour moi ça
s'appelle un comédien
merci georges lautner de votre
témoignage merci beaucoup
le reste de l'actualité maintenant
michel rocard tape du poing sur la table
la corse at il dit a atteint le plafond
de solidarité qu'elle peut attendre du
continent en réaffirmant ainsi le
discours qu'il tient depuis le début du
conflit
le premier ministre a voulu faire preuve
de fermeté une nouvelle fois il ne veut
pas céder aux fonctionnaires corse qui
bloque lille écoutez ce que disait
monsieur rocard tout à l'heure devant
les parlementaires socialistes
l'état sait fort bien que l'accord sera
atteint le plafond de la solidarité
le plafond de la solidarité qu'elle peut
attendre du continent et que le problème
n'est pas d'y transférer plus d'argent
mais éventuellement voir même
certainement de transférer ce même
argent autre homme
parlons-en en détail discutons tableront
réformant mais de grâce que l'on ne
demande pas aux contribuables
continentaux de prendre à leur charge
les marges abusives que s'attribue
certains intermédiaires cela aucun
gouvernement ne peut l'accepter en tout
cas pas le mien mais c'est pas parce
qu'il vient parce que nous sommes
socialistes et au moment où le premier
ministre faisait ses déclarations les
corses manifester encore à bastia mais
dans le calme cette fois alors comment
ont-ils réagi aux propos de monsieur
rocard françoise joly notre envoyé
spécial est sur place à bastia une
tension omniprésente des face à face
tout
l'udc à l'insu dans l'affrontement
éviter parfois grâce à un ultime sursaut
de 100 fois et pourtant aujourd'hui
l'exercice de la fonction publique
étaient encore plusieurs milliers dans
les rues mais les syndicats veillette au
calme peut-être dans l'espoir que la
situation se débloque
une chose est sûre les organisations
syndicales sont unanimes au moins sur un
point
plus question d'aller négocier à paris
sans avoir des propositions concrètes et
chiffrées ce soir ici à bastia objet de
tous les débats les derniers propos de
michel rocard
le premier ministre a précisé
aujourd'hui que la cour n'aurait pas
plus d'argent mais que ses services
veillerait à ce qu'il soit mieux
distribuer une déclaration plutôt mal
accueillie par les syndicats
encore pourquoi qu'il faut bien
dissocier leur problème social qui
l'argent il problèmes économiques il
faut qu'ils comprennent que nous restons
attachés à l'ensemble des revendications
que nous avons déposées
que nous restons attachés à des
négociations véritables et que nous ne
dérogerons pas dedans plus en ce qui
concerne les négociations dans ce
contexte difficile de savoir si de
nouvelles négociations pourront
s'engager avant la fin de cette sixième
semaine de grève
le mystère de la mosquée de bruxelles
qui a tué lienemann et son
bibliothécaire et pourquoi il ya
plusieurs hypothèses
l'une d'entre elles est liée à l'affairé
rushdie bien sûr car liman al adel
étaient saoudiens et il était plutôt
modéré dans cette affaire mais il est
encore trop tôt pour affirmer que les
deux hommes sont les premières victimes
de cette affaire au jeudi
enquête à bruxelles bruno gex une chose
est sûre le recteur de la mosquée de
bruxelles
abdallah a la dalle a été assassiné par
des professionnels la même arme du 7 65
à tuer le bibliothécaire du centre
islamique de façon identique
seuls des familiers des lieux pouvait
s'introduire dans la mosquée sans
éveiller l'attention
police de bruxelles le 24 mars a été
averti par le concert ch de centre
islamique
comme quoi un appel téléphonique anonyme
était arrivé là bas et par laquelle des
menaces de mort avaient été exprimées il
s'agissait surtout de l'attitude très
modérée de l'imam en question dans la
question de rochdi le 8 mars dernier
abdallah à la dalle accordait une
interview à la dernière heure toujours à
propos de salman rushdie
il en était aussi question à la
télévision belge
un mois plus tard la première l'idée
passe ce sont des intégristes musulmans
mais aussi l'extrême droite européenne
pourra avoir sa main dans ce travail les
deux sont mêlés l'un se servant de
l'autre éventuellement
je pense qu'ils ne sont pas mêlés dans
la préparation ne dont l'objectif est le
même c'est évident que cet acte ne sert
que l'extrême droite on aura plus si les
seuls aussi à diviser encore le droit le
monde musulman une dernière hypothèse
celle d'un conflit de personnes à
l'intérieur de la mosquée abdallah a la
dalle était contestée c'est peut-être là
qu'il faut chercher l'explication
après ce double meurtre d'autres
islamique modéré s'inquiète ainsi le
chef spirituel de la mosquée de paris
chez qu'abbas a demandé la protection de
la police
il n'est pas le seul à s'inquiéter
quelles sont les mesures de sécurité
prises autour d'eux réponse hervé
brusini à la grande mosquée de paris
périmètre de sécurité présence policière
mais pas de tension apparente depuis le
double assassinat de bruxelles
simplement la vigilence vigilence le
maître mot des autorités qui affirment
avoir mis en place un dispositif de
sécurité
dès le début de l'affairé ruby dans la
capitale des lieux définis comme
sensibles font l'objet de surveillances
le siège des journaux des éditeurs qui
ont pris position à propos des versets
sataniques sont sur le parcours des
rondes et patrouilles des forces de
police même chose pour le domicile de
quelques personnalités les mosquées
associations musulmanes sap ou appeler
en cas d'événement suspect sur le reste
du territoire les préfets et les
services de police ont tous reçu le même
type de consignes
la bavure de l'aéroport distro
l'aéroport de londres elle fait rire et
puis elle donne froid dans le dos un
bâton de dynamite dont on s'était servi
pour répéter des exercices de sécurité
ce bâton de dynamite avait été oublié
dans un avion et l'avion a fait le tour
du monde avec une nouvelle fois se pose
le problème de la sécurité à heathrow
philippe harrouard à londres c'est un
bâton de gels et need comme celui ci qui
a été découvert par un employé de
nettoyage dans un 747 de la british
airways
il a été oublié sous un siège après un
exercice de sécurité auxquels
participent des chiens renifleurs
dans ce cas ils ont manqué de flair et
l'explosivité rester en plaques
lorsque le bo a repris son service
normal autour du mont embarras de la
police qui explique que sans détonateur
il ya peu de chances d'explosion quand
même
la semaine dernière trois jeunes
londoniens à la suite d'un pari on
pénétrer clandestinement la nuit dans un
boeing vide à iqra n'ai vu ni connu
ils ont même filmé leur escapade et
s'ils avaient été des terroristes
embarras vendredi deux journaux
britanniques révèle une information top
secret sur un possible détournement d'un
avion américain par des terroristes du
moyen orient
une fuite qui provoque la colère des
autorités américaines qui estiment que
la discrétion est essentiel dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
après cela comment expliquer aux
malheureux passagers des aéroports que
pour des raisons de sécurité bien
compréhensible ils devront subir de
longues et minutieuses trouille
engendrant d'importants retards dans les
vols mais qu'ensuite tout ira bien
en principe
la médecine avec l'étrange déclarations
du professeur escande dans une interview
à l'express le professeur escande qui
coordonne le groupe sida de l'hôpital
cochin affirme que l'épidémie du sida
est pratiquement enrayer alors aulaqi
bien surprenant lorsqu'on sait que tous
les jours de nouvelles personnes sont
contaminées et que tous les jours la
maladie fait des victimes en france et
dans le monde entier
mais pour monsieur escande la prévention
et l'hygiène ont été telle qu'on voit le
bout du tunnel dans cette maladie la
plupart de ses confrères contestent
cette analyse
enquête jean daniel flaysakier le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que le
professeur eske en n'y va pas avec le
dos de la cuillère dans ses déclarations
à notre confrère l'express
pour lui il est temps de crier au moins
partiellement victoire mais voilà dans
la communauté médicale
rares sont ceux qui sont prêts à
entonner le même chante lui certes
l'épidémie qui devait dévasté le globe
est restée du domaine du fantasme mais
en revanche rien n'est pourtant réglé
avec le sida les spécialistes voient
chaque jour de nouveaux cas de
contamination par le virus hiv
responsable de la maladie même si les
groupes à risque et en particulier les
homosexuels sont aujourd'hui moins
touchées c'est vrai l'information passe
et la prévention fonctionne mais ce
n'est pas pour autant qu'il faut baisser
les bras car le mal est là ils restent
encore parmi nous est le négligé serait
catastrophique
en tous les cas les pouvoirs publics ne
sont pas très content des déclarations
du professeur escande l'épidémie de sida
existe encore le risque auquel on est
exposé si on ne prend pas des
précautions
lorsqu'on a une situation à risque
existe encore cela que je retiens et
c'est cela que j'ai envie de réduire
très fortement pour éviter toute
tentative de démobilisation qui serait
tout à fait prématuré si l'on veut se
convaincre de la réalité du danger il
suffit de regarder le nombre de cas
déclarés à l'organisation mondiale de la
santé depuis huit ans des cas qui sont
cinq à dix fois inférieur à la réalité
et puisque nous parlons de sida cette
brochure qui sera distribuée à un
million deux cent mille exemplaires cela
s'intitule sida et travail
elle vient d'être présentée par le
ministre du travail jean pierre soisson
des informations sur le sida et surtout
cette affirmation le sida ne doit pas
être traitée différemment des autres
malades
dit dans les milieux professionnels la
politique on connaît ce soir la tête de
liste communiste pour les élections
européennes
il s'agit de philippe herzog un
polytechnicien de 49 ans qui est aussi
le spécialiste des problèmes économiques
au pc bruno roger-petit heureux georges
marchais qui approuvait la solution
philippe herzog conduira la liste
communiste aux élections européennes de
juin prochain philippe herzog un fidèle
du parti communiste et de georges
marchais un intellectuel comme on dit
avec respect dans le parti un
polytechnicien et économiste de 49 ans
qui est même membre du bureau politique
toujours présent et approbateurs lors
des grand messes communiste cet
observateur éclairé de la vie de son
parent qui se voit confier une tâche
délicate confirmer la remontée de
l'influencé du pc remontée revendiquée
par georges marchais durant ces deux
jours de session du comité central en
1984 le secrétaire général avait
recueilli 11 % des voix 11% des voix
pour le pc d'alors c'était un échec en
juin prochain
place du colonel fabien un tel score
pourrait être analysé comme un succès
nouvelle inculpation dans la sphère des
fausses factures du sud est cette fois
c'est schaus quaglia le maire de la
seyne sur mer qui a été inculpé de
corruption complicité de faux en
écriture et recel d'abus de biens
sociaux
monsieur skywilly a été inculpé tout à
l'heure dans le cadre de l'instruction
de cette affaire de pots-de-vin et de
fausses factures de la sorba et le
président mitterrand
en italie il a rencontré le chef du
gouvernement italien monsieur demi-tasse
était dans la paisible petite ville de
villégiature de taormina en sicile
les deux hommes ont beaucoup parlé de
l'europe monétaire et social
et puis le président français s'est
expliqué sur sa prochaine rencontre avec
yasser arafat le leader de l'olp et
monsieur rafa tu viens en france et
monsieur mitterrand le rencontrera
monsieur mitterrand a expliqué pourquoi
c'était à taormina tout à l'heure en
sicile
les autres ont discuté avec monsieur
rares à pattes habits monsieur
mitterrand c'est bien ce que j'ai
l'intention de faire
c'était aujourd'hui la dernière
négociation pour lionel jospin sur la
loi d'orientation de l'enseignement elle
ne s'est pas terminée dans l'
enthousiasme pour les parents d'élèves
déçue elle manque de souffle
les syndicalistes la trouve trop floue
bref au total
lionel jospin n'a pas obtenu l'accueil
qu'il espérait pour son projet éducatif
officiellement les négociations sont
terminées mais les contacts continuent
en coulisses à l'étranger israël et la
journée de la terre c'est une journée
très importante pour les arabes qui
vivent en israël car ils protestent
contre les expropriations les
palestiniens des territoires occupés
manifestent leur solidarité
il ya encore eu des affrontements et des
victimes quatre morts et une trentaine
de blessés
charles enderlin les notables arabe
israélien avait donné la consigne
surtout pas d'affrontements avec la
police
ils ont donc canaliser le mouvement pour
que la journée se passe avec au moins
d'incidents possible
deux manifestations de masse se sont
déroulées la première tira au nord de
tel-aviv où c'est un événement le chef
des islamistes serrer la main des
leaders communistes
c'est une journée de lutte pour
l'égalité des droits en israël et
oscille journée de solidarité pour la
création d'un état palestinien aux côtés
d'israël dans la paix et la sécurité
la nouvelle génération bharati serait
bien à elle un ton plus dur
hilti fada le soulèvement palestinien
est formidable si nous n'obtenons pas
nos droits en israël nous aussi nous
nous soulèverons les forces de l'ordre
veillaient au grain quelques kilomètres
plus loin
très peu d'incidents également galinée a
dit rana loin mythe il a réuni des
milliers de manifestants toutes
tendances confondues des
fondamentalistes aux communistes dans
les territoires la situation était
extrêmement tendue
les palestiniens ont fait grève
plusieurs localités de cisjordanie sont
sous couvre feu
ainsi que l'ensemble de la bande de gaza
et au proche orient beyrouth toujours
sous les obus nous allons le voir ainsi
que d'autres informations
internationales de ce jeudi avec éric
perrin
reprise au liban des bombardements
syrien sur le secteur chrétiens de
beyrouth
est ce ce matin l'explosion d'un
réservoir de gaz du complexe de doha
cible des tirs syriens depuis quatre
jours a secoué toute la ville blessant
cent quarante et une personnes et des
garçons très important hier soir à une
dizaine de kilomètres au sud est de
beyrouth
un reporter photographe français alain
noguès a été blessé par des éclats
d'obus séjours sont hors de danger
les mutins du pénitencier de pavone au
guatemala accepte de se rendre à la
suite des propositions du gouvernement
réduction de peine minimum de cinq ans
pour tous les prisonniers remplacement
des gardiens et du directeur de
l'établissement
les 500 otages restants détenus depuis
quatre jours devrait être libéré dans la
nuit
attentat contre le consulat du maroc à
lyon une charge apparemment de faible
puissance a explosé en pleine nuit ne
provoquant que des dégâts matériels
une action qui n'a toujours pas été
revendiqué la mort du général gambier il
était âgé de 86 ans il avait été
commandant en chef en algérie pendant le
putsch des généraux en avril 61
il s'est éteint la nuit dernière encore
des arrestations dans les milieux de la
drogue aux états unis ce serait la plus
importante opération contre le
blanchiment de l'argent de la drogue 127
personnes ont été arrêtées et deux
banques sont inculpés dominique
verdeilhan arrestation record doublée
d'une saisie record 127 personnes ont
été arrêtés par le fbi et la brigade
anti drogue qui ont également mis la
main sur un beau pactole une demi tonne
de cocaïne
la somme de 45 millions de dollars soit
270 millions de francs mais aussi les
bijoux les joailleries sont aussi
orfèvre dans le blanchiment d'argent de
la drogue pour avoir blanchi 1 milliard
de dollars deux banques
latino-américaines ont été inculpés d'
association de malfaiteurs
elles sont impliquées dans un réseau
international liée au puissant cartel
colombien de medellin
un cartel qui est considéré comme le
pourvoyeur de 80% de la cocaïne
consommée aux états unis se félicitant
de ce coup de filet le ministre
américain de la justice a indiqué que
son pays et le panama continuer à
coopérer en dépit de l'inculpation pour
trafic de drogue du général final ring
le sport football d'abord avec le tirage
au sort des huitièmes de finale de la
coupe de france voici le tableau que je
vous laisse regarder pour retrouver vos
clubs favoris que vous allez supporter
pour ces huitièmes de finale moi je note
les chocs en bas du tableau l'as entre
nantes et monaco et entre marseille et
toulon l'automobile quinze jours après
l'accident de philippe streiff
grièvement blessé alain prost et les
pousses de philippe streiff viennent de
présenter un projet il s'agit
d'installer au bord des circuits de
formule 1 une antenne chirurgicale
les deux alain prost et madame streiff
ont pris contact avec les plus grands
chirurgiens spécialistes
coût du projet 10 millions de français
cher bien sûr mais ce n'est rien par
rapport aux sommes énormes mise en jeu
dans les courses de formule
thierry blancot l'accident de philippe
streiff il ya quinze jours au brésil a
mis en évidence les carences au niveau
des moyens existants pour assurer la
sécurité des pilotes au cours des essais
accident tragique et transport qui
relève du cauchemar diagnostic immédiat
fracture de la clavicule une simple
minerve
en guise de protection rien de
véritablement efficace pour éviter
l'aggravation de l'état de santé du
pilote au cours de son transfert à la
clinique de sao vicente
tout ce qui s'est passé avec philippe à
rio a été a été une aberration est un
scandale
vraiment un scandale il est scandaleux
de ne pas transporter un pilote blessé
gravement atteints aux vertèbres dans un
matelas coquille avec une minerve
lorsqu'on sait les prix que coûte un
matelas coquille et une minerve
la formule 1 est un laboratoire
technologique extraordinaire
les voitures progressent les
performances augmentent le profil des
circuits lui ne bouge pas les plus
question de polémique ou de ou de
problèmes entre les parties en plus de
divisions entre le pouvoir sportif où
les constructeurs où les pilotes c'est
maintenant tous ont semblé essayons de
que ce problème dans nautique se
reproduisent comme une antenne
chirurgicale sur les circuits peuvent
être mises en place dans les trois mois
si l'appel d'alain prost et de rené
streiff est entendu en tennis yannick
noah qualifier il jouera les demi
finales du tournoi de key biscayne c'est
l'un des plus grands des cinq plus
grands tournois de tennis du monde il a
battu chinois a battu l'allemand steib
en trois sets en demi finale il
rencontrera l'autrichien moster l'autre
demi finale ce sera lendl contre que
rennes et les oscars nous y venons
c'était la nuit dernière à hollywood le
film rain man et grand vainqueur avec
notamment l'oscar du meilleur acteur
pour dustin hoffman et puis une surprise
qui répare une injustice le français
marcel ophuls reçoit l'oscar du meilleur
documentaire pour hôtel terminus claude
ganne hier était notre envoyé spécial à
hollywood la nuit dernière où la grande
vedette était hier soir
oscar reporter l'âge vedettes de
l'actualité c'est luis oscar et
hollywood se croit la capitale du monde
c'est sans doute vrai si on en juge par
le nombre de caméras et de journalistes
là pour vous montrer quarantaine de on
est toujours prêt à faire face à toutes
les situations
j'ai amené avec moi quelques ustensiles
très utile voilà on est toujours
beaucoup mieux sur les hauteurs et ça
permet de dire bonjour à quelques amis
olivia newton john
chakim bis et cher ami candice bergen et
sigourney weaver et de voir les autres
geena davis et jeff goldblum
michael caine chef et l'autriche de père
et le fils tom selleck
et dustin hoffman l'acteur le plus
attendu consacré par l'apu avant leur
meilleur acteur c'est m ce ballet de
limousines qui vise à perpétuer les
splendeurs d'hollywood et y parvient et
est la meilleure partie de cette
cérémonie des oscars la 61e le reste
était moins bien pour un programme
destiné à un milliard et demi de
téléspectateurs trop américains ont fait
mieux aux folies bergères et trop parler
sauf pour les français qui vont s'y
retrouver jacques hingis et candice
bergen les pousses de louis malle feront
leur annonce en français oui y'a un
violent coup d'oeil dans le frigo
et pour leurs performances se feront à
applaudir comment peut-on parler princes
marcel ophuls expliquera-t-elle à deux
pays la france où il est né et
l'amérique qu'il aime pour son film
hôtel terminus la vie le temps de cars
barbie il va remporter l'oscar du
meilleur documentaire de cinéma st et je
voudrais aussi remercier le montage le
bien en cours dudit foster qui a fait
toutes ses études dans un lycée français
à los angeles sera consacrée meilleure
actrice pour son rôle d'henri acuse
l'accusé cela dit le triomphe ira au
film rain man 4 oscars
il obtient les prix du meilleur acteur
meilleur scénario original meilleur
réalisateur barry levinson sans
hésitation le meilleur film de l'année
les résultats du tiercé c'était à saint
cloud aujourd'hui je vous les donne
voici l'ordre d'arrivée pour ce tiercé
4,7 aph 7461 francs et gros tiercé dans
l'ordre fait 144 francs dans le désordre
le quarté 4,7 aph et 11 271 1100 de
francs dans l'ordre 15 1914 150 dans le
désordre fin du journal tout de suite la
météo avec laurent cabrol
il annonce quelques orages dernière
édition ce sera henri sannier à demain
soir 20h